hoy en directo vamos a Washington este
miércoles el departamento de estado
confirmó que Anthony blinken viajar a
China este domingo una esperada visita
oficial Que Fue aplazada en Febrero por
la controversia que desató el sobrevuelo
de un presunto globo espía chino por
territorio estadounidense conectamos en
la capital estadounidense con Cristóbal
Vázquez corresponsal de France 24
Cristobal en medio de las tensiones
entre ambas potencias Cuál es el
principal objetivo de este viaje
Anthony viajará del 16 al 21 irá China y
también estará en Londres el principal
objetivo según el departamento de estado
es mantener abiertas las líneas de
comunicación dijo que va a traer en las
conversaciones que va a tener con altos
oficiales de la República popular china
temas de preocupación tanto regionales
como globales y también explorar
posibilidad de tener cooperación en el
futuro en término en temas de cambio
climático en temas tecnológicos y en
temas económicos china Pues en repetidas
ocasiones le ha dicho Estados Unidos que
precisamente No utilice el tema de la
competencia el argumento de la
competencia para afectar los intereses
de seguridad de la República popular
china
actualmente Cuál es el estado de las
relaciones entre Beijing y Washington
Pues hay varios temas que no hacen que
la relación de estos dos países estén
bien uno de ellos y posiblemente el
principal es el tema de Taiwán
acompañado de la importancia de Taiwán
viene la guerra tecnológica por los
semiconductores que son pequeños
elementos que se usan en todas de todo
tipo de computadores en todo tipo de
elementos electrónicos que usamos en el
día a día y que tanto china como Estados
Unidos están tratando de fabricar para
poder tener Independencia tecnológica
pero también está el tema de que la
semana pasada un avión espía
estadounidense sobrevolaba aguas
internacionales cerca al mar al mar sur
del sur de China y varios aviones varios
jets de China interceptaron hicieron
maniobras agresivas y frente a esto pues
hubo roces que seguramente serán
abordados en este diálogo pero es de
Resaltar que en las últimas semanas
tanto el presidente de uno de los bancos
más grandes acá en Estados Unidos JP
Morgan viajó a China y también el
director de la Cia viajó a China en un
viaje que muy poco se habló de este pero
que precisamente muestra que las líneas
de comunicación están abiertas y se
quieren mantener así